today President Trump tweeted that his
son Donald Jr is quote open transparent
and innocent that's what he said open
transparent innocent which is why
President Trump is now demanding a
paternity test he said is that God oh
[Applause]
that's what he said though that was his
tweet his tweet is that Donald Jr is
open transparent and innocent
unfortunately those are three things you
don't want to be when you go to prison
[Applause]
old friends are coming out of the
woodwork to talk about Donald Trump jr.
oh yeah yeah they're coming out of the
woodwork according to friends of Donald
Trump juniors back in college he was a
blackout drunk yeah yeah so he does have
a long history of meeting with White
Russians
[Applause]
I got one zinger after another tonight
here's another one yeah it was reported
today it's reported today that Donald
Trump juniors wife once dated Leonardo
DiCaprio yeah
in other words she's used to being with
guys who go down with a sinking ship so
I'm thinking of left and right tonight
Andi is crazy it's being reported that
President Trump you know what really
bothers him apparently what really
bothers him is that people think he
watches too much television
that's what apparently he's saying he's
saying it bothers him that people think
he watches too much television
Trump claims he saw it mentioned today
on the view the Today Show CNN live with
Kelly and Ryan and Clifford the Big Red
Dog
[Applause]
you